[Applause]
hi everyone thanks for being here so my
story starts in 2012 Obama was president
yeah pick up for that I was living in
New York City I was working at a big ad
agency on Park Avenue I was working with
big brands big budgets I was on the
strategic side of creative which meant I
was using both sides of my brain all the
time and so things on paper seemed
pretty good but I was stuck and feeling
unfulfilled and realized that I needed a
change I took some time to reflect and
realize that over the past few years
working at this big agency I I had
decided that I was no longer drawn to
climbing the corporate ladder there were
too much politics too much red tape I
couldn't get anything done that I really
felt passionate about I also realized
that over the past few years I was
consciously disengaging from the work
that I was doing because by the time or
once we started we would have these big
ideas everyone get really excited about
them and by the time they saw the light
of day and ended up somewhere in the
world they were so different than what
we actually created they had basically
all ended up all the good stuff had
ended up on the cutting room floor and I
was just really frustrating and being
able to recognize that you know made me
realize that it was time to do something
different
meanwhile I had all these friends
working at startups both in LA and New
York and what I saw from them was
something entirely different they were
passionate about what they were doing
they were like deciding to bail on
dinner plans with me without even
thinking twice because they wanted to
work all night and for some reason that
seems very appealing to me also so what
I what I decided was you know for me to
feel this professional satisfaction what
I needed was to be making an impact
I needed to be building something to be
creating something that I could then see
out in the world and I took it a step
further and realized that I actually
wanted to create something physical
something that I could hold and touch
and use and that people could use around
me but I wasn't sure what that was I
knew that I was looking for this greater
purpose and a job that I could also you
know bail on dinner and
and work all night and be excited to do
so so I decided this is the summer I
decided to give myself till the end of
the year to figure out what I was gonna
do next and so you know I did what most
people do is start putting out the
feelers I started talking to all of my
friends that worked in startups to
understand what they were doing and what
they thought I could be doing based on
my experience and one night out to
drinks with a good friend of mine I had
been probably complaining for the
majority of the time I even spent we
were spending together you know just
upset about what I was doing and feeling
like I didn't know what to do next and
you know how would what I was doing it
advertising translate to something else
and he looked at me and just interrupted
me and said you know I don't think you
should be looking for what's next in a
new company like you should start your
own company I see this founder in you
and I've never said this before but I
really believe in you and that took me
by surprise I was not thinking oh it's
time to go start my own company next
like I've I went to I didn't go to
business school you know all these
things that you hear about that
I didn't identify with that but after
that conversation that that idea and
that thought really stuck to me and I
started to kind of dig deep and think
about you know what was it that I was
really passionate about where could I
find you know this sense of fulfillment
and desire to build and learn and keep
growing I've always been obsessed with
home and interior design I used to help
friends and family decorate their homes
just for fun which meant that I was
doing a lot of shopping with them not my
money which also made it more fun I also
had an interior design blog long before
blogs were cool like in 2006 and while I
went through grad school and so you know
that was it was something that I was
really into and so you know I found
myself one day shopping for bedding and
had one of those lightning strikes
moment when you least expect it and I it
was in this big box retailer and I think
probably many of you have had this
experience before shopping for sheets or
for towels or something in these
enormous rooms where there's Florida
stack ceiling stacked products
everything
completely undifferentiated no one can
help you and I was like this is the
worst like this experience is the worst
there's no differentiation everything is
in packaging that I can't touch you know
I think it could be better and I
identified this void in the market so I
spent a lot of time thinking more about
the home category and really
understanding where I could fit in and
and what I would want to do and and how
ultimately I could affect change and
that led me to the bedroom because you
spend a xxx relief in bed and sleep
impacts everything your happiness your
productivity and what I realized in one
of these like aha moments for me was you
know how is it possible that at this day
and age there had never been a bedding
brand that it asked me how I slept at
night like you'd think at some point
someone would be like hey you're
sleeping like let's make this better and
so again this is 2012 we're getting
closer to the end of the year at this
point but this is when a lot of
direct-to-consumer businesses were
really starting to gain momentum and I
also saw that that was really appealing
to me and to my peers and that the you
know there was this new way to shop that
felt much more authentic and through my
experience and advertising and working
with consumers and really understanding
what motivates them I saw this trend
that people really were taking time and
spending their money to invest in
themselves and so it became clear to me
what I was going to do and how I was
gonna make impact and so now it's 2013
it's been about a year since this whole
process started I left my job I moved to
LA to start parachute and I was back in
New York and decided to meet my old boss
and I showed him my pitch deck and I was
all giddy with excitement and also kind
of scared with the unknown but had
product and we were having coffee and
you know at some point he again
interrupted me and he was said you know
you should have left advertising a long
time ago like I said it's clear that
this is what you were meant to do and he
was right and so you know I realized at
this moment that I had had this founder
inside of me all along but I was really
looking for someone to give me
permission and to give me this push to
go do something on my own
it wasn't something that it ever
registered and so I'll leave you with
this this is my parting words of wisdom
don't wait and give yourself that push
you don't need to wait for anyone and
dream big
[Applause]